see it's very difficult to speak
phenomenally and not be great but to be
what unfreaking forgettable it's
difficult to be Unforgettable while
you're still trying to look good see
Unforgettable has everything to do with
serving at a level so high so big so
massive that people feel like they have
to change their lives because they
crossed your path you got to recognize
that that no matter your past you were
given a voice and your voice was given
not to keep to yourself your voice is
not a secret and you have to be willing
to use every experience that's ever
happened in your life not as a fortress
holding you from using your voice but as
the fuel on why you will use your voice
you got to be willing to not stand in
your story but stand on your story it's
not in spite of your past that you get
to be amazing that you get to be a
change agent it's because of your past
that you're perfect for such a job when
you own it like that see there's no
question in my certainty about my my
life can you walk with that level of
certainty so that when the wind comes
and then when the wind blows and it will
come and it will blow and it will be a
storm when it comes it will rock you it
will rock you it will rock you but it
won't move you
humans are built to serve if you are not
happy it's because you do not feel like
you are serving people if you wake up
and you're not happy you feel like today
doesn't matter today doesn't count
nobody cares if you show up or not
that's the path down to anxiety and
stress and depression and suicide
because you feel like you don't belong
because it feels like you could spend
all day working on something and
nobody's going to care
that's the feeling that nobody wants
right you don't want to wake up and feel
like you're going to spend all day today
and nobody will care
how do you get people to Care by serving
by helping we all want to wake up and
feel like today is gonna count it's
gonna mean something to somebody and
maybe today is the big day that you get
that big news or the big deal or the big
contract or the big subscriber goal or
whatever your goals are maybe it's that
day
but those goals aren't enough
how many times have you hit a goal and
realized oh that's it right you feel
great have that happen if you like oh I
got a million subscribers and then then
what what does that mean
and it's off to the next goal if you're
just living for little sugar highs
you're not having happiness at the
foundational level in your life
because you don't feel like you're
serving
we have to tie the work that we do into
serving it's feeling like today is going
to mean something if you woke up today
and felt like today was going to mean
something
today was gonna matter
that I'm gonna put something out into
the world I'm gonna make this YouTube
video I'm just sitting here in my office
or standing on my trampoline in my
office that I'm going to make something
today that will matter that will touch
somebody if I felt that
I'm gonna show up totally differently
than like oh whatever another video okay
who cares
you know required hey Evan yeah yeah
next right you just show up differently
based off your feeling about yourself
that you're doing something that's going
to serve people
so if you're struggling with that and
you're you're coming up with your list
of goals and you've got your dream board
and you've got your Lamborghini and your
vacation home and the airplane and a
fancy hotel those are not the things
that will make you happy those are not
your real goals that's a fake dream
board
the thing that will make you sustainably
happy is feeling like you're serving
and the next level of it is either
serving more deeply or more broadly
you take the people who are closest to
you and you really focus on helping them
and help improve their lives in a
significant way or you're going to reach
a lot more people
but if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving
so how do you do it how do you how do
you serve at a higher level it'll give
you three quick ideas that I think will
help number one
there's a process I go through it's
called who I have so number one is your
who your who is your single most
important core value what is your single
most important core value I write about
this and and build the serve you can go
check it out if you want your single
most important core value what is it
for me it's belief
for you maybe it's believed too but
maybe a good chance that it's something
else but your single most important core
value
as you go through it I found that it's
funny how everybody's core value is
something positive this is why I believe
people are good
because I've never had somebody's core
value come back as hate or death or be
toxic right never it's always something
aspirational positive which means that
people are good we do things that we're
not proud of we we sometimes are
negative to others because we're in a
lot of pain at that moment but deep down
at a core level humans are good so you
figure out your single most important
core value what is it don't worry about
being perfect just even right now what
comes to mind what what single word is
really important to you right now a core
value
great
how you can serve is to bring more of
that to yourself and then to bring more
of that to other people
the ultimate service for me is believing
more in myself so then I can believe
more in other people as well the goal of
making these videos is to help you
believe in yourself more to help the
world believe in themselves more to
unlock the Michael Jordan level genius
that we all have inside of us that
you're the best in the world that's
something what is it I don't know I hope
you do but if not let's Discover it and
send it out to the world
your ultimate happiness satisfaction Joy
fulfillment will yes come from serving
other people but in for me believing in
them if I could help even through this
video or conversation or a clubhouse or
a live session
if I knew that I was going to say
something that would help even one
person on the call believing themselves
a little bit more
mission accomplished
so adding Clarity you know you want to
serve you know if you're not happy
you're not serving great
how the first level of clarity is you're
who your single most important core
value figure out what that is even if
you have a starting point in order being
perfect
the more that you can help yourself and
others believe that thing the more happy
you will be
next level down is your why so Point
number two is your why your why is your
purpose and your purpose comes from your
pain so whatever you struggled the most
with is the thing you want to help other
people through it's great to hold the
door for somebody or buy the coffee
behind in line or or buy somebody a
balloon or give a sandwich to somebody
who's you know hungry like all those
things are great it's great these
momentary acts of kindness are fantastic
amazing do more of them
what will fill you up on an even deeper
level is recognizing that your ultimate
purpose your why
comes from helping people who currently
are who you used to be
go back to the moment in your life where
you felt the the lowest the loneliness
the least uh the least level of
confidence you've ever had in yourself
when did you feel worthless as a human
what was that moment
hopefully it's not right now it's
probably not right now if you're
watching these videos because you're
you're on your way up
go back to when you would never watch
one of these videos go back to when it
was just the worst day of your life when
was that for you you've come through
you're not done you're not done climbing
growing learning getting better you're
still a long way from where you want to
be and that's amazing
and you're way further than you used to
be
your why your purpose is to help the
people who currently are who you used to
be
they'll look to you and see
guidance hope encouragement support
inspiration motivation because you're
ahead
of where they are right now the you from
five years ago would look to you and be
inspired right the the Advent from five
years ago from 10 years ago you look at
10 years 10 years ago on YouTube I had I
don't know 100 subscribers
he's trying to make 10-year goals I
would never predict that I'd be here 10
years ago Evan is looking to advantages
like you did all that oh my gosh it's
crazy but we never Pat ourselves on the
back and give ourselves enough credit
for those things
and there are millions of people right
now who are struggling with the same
thing
whatever you struggled with
there are millions of people who are
struggling with that same thing right
now and they need you they need your
voice they need your help they need
support they need your guidance they
need your encouragement they need your
words they need you they need you and
helping those people will feel
so much better than just doing a random
act of kindness It's just levels of
service right random back behind this
great little candy but deep fulfillment
will be from helping the people who
currently are who you used to be that's
your why that's your purpose it will
never get old you'll love doing that for
the rest of your life
and then step number three is the how
the how is how did you get out of the
hole you were in what were the steps
that you took so for me getting out of
the hole that I was in where the worst
day of my life was quitting on my
business partner in my first company
how to get out of the hole while I
modeled success
and I tried a million different things
you know and modeling success was just a
a desperation play you know like okay oh
my gosh I don't know what else to do who
else has done this so Bill Gates started
a software company what did he do I felt
like I was grasping a straw it's like I
had no idea what I was doing
it was just an idea that came the man
was willing to try anything at that
point because the other alternative was
just to quit on my company and go find a
job
now luckily that was the one that
actually ended up working out
and now anytime when I don't know what
to do something I try to model success
like who's done this thing and how can I
learn from them instead of having to
reinvent the wheel every time
and so what have I done for the past
20 years oh my gosh 20 years what have I
done for the past 20 years
teach people how they can model success
too
right
the how matters how you got out of the
hole that you were in you can then teach
other people what worked for you you
tried all these things that didn't work
and you almost gave up and then you
found something that did kind of work
and then you worked on it and you
improved it and you refined it that is
now teachable to other people
show them the process to get out of the
hole
because they don't see any help and they
think they're stuck for life
in your story your message will help
pull them out in a way that
Evan Carmichael can't in a way that Lisa
Nichols can't in a way that Tony Robbins
can't in a way that anybody can but you
can because you are exactly
the person that they need to hear from
because you've gone through exactly the
problem that they are struggling with
you're who you're why you're how it's
all been built to surf
that's your path
if you're not happy it's because you're
not serving
you feel like today doesn't matter it
doesn't mean anything to anybody else
and you flip that
just by reminding yourself
of Who You Are
of why you do what you do
and how you got out of the hole so you
can feel like today will mean something
to somebody else and then if you keep
showing up consistently every day and
putting in the work the impact that you
will have on this planet
will inspire you
to a level that you can't even imagine
right now
you are built to serve also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
oh my God I love this question I don't
think I've ever been asked this question
before I've never had an opportunity to
explain it being the best version of you
first of all it's not don't think of it
holistic I want you to break it down to
different parts of your life because
when you are committed to being the best
version of you which in summary it's the
you that you're so incredibly proud of
holistically it's a 360 approach it says
I'm not perfect
so Beth does not mean the perfect
version of you because I think
Perfection and balance are two illusions
that are designed to help you keep
chasing something that's not even
attainable so perfect is not attainable
and balance is not attainable so it's
perfectly managing my imperfection and
releasing balance and having Harmony
number one
but the best version of you is really
saying that in each area of my life I'm
in movement in each area of my life I'm
an evolution in each area of my life I'm
active I am actively participating in an
upwardly way in an upperly mobile way in
this area of my life times every area of
my life it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're always where you want to be but
it does mean that you're being
responsible you're being active and
you're being proactive finances that
you're looking at your numbers just this
morning just this morning I ran my
credit score again I want to see what's
on it I want to be actively
participating in my financial growth I
looked at my savings I looked at my life
insurance I just looked at my my
long-term plan not necessarily because I
want to buy another house or I want to
buy a car I just want to be on top of it
I want to be responsible for it and then
health and wellness Jesse yesterday I
was talking to Matt and going Matt it's
time for us to do another health and
wellness campaign I don't I don't
necessarily want to do it and it's
slightly to moderately scares me a bit
when I'm bringing my fitness into a
public conversation but I know the
responsible me the best version of Lisa
is saying hold me accountable hold me
accountable to my fitness goals hold me
accountable to my Total Wellness goals
and then last week I was just sitting
with someone saying you know what I need
to go down the list of all the checkups
that I've had I need to make sure I'm
not missing anything
relationships I just said to a
girlfriend yesterday hold me accountable
hold me accountable to not running
I realize that I run well and I run
smoothly I run like a gazelle sometimes
when it comes to relationships you don't
it doesn't even look like I'm running
because I'm so busy so I asked someone
who knows me who knows the love that I
want who knows my sexy excuses
I need you to hold me accountable when I
say this I want you to question it and
so while there's so much growth in every
area of my life I'm being the best
version that I know to be because I'm
active in every single area I'm not
saying I'm being the best or I am the
best please don't get me wrong with that
I'm just saying to be the best version
of myself so when you look at being the
best version of yourself look at each
part of your life and go what am I
actively doing where you feel like I'm
in the game in this area I'm not
resigned and I'm not praying for it to
go right or I'm not in resignation and
in complaint about it I'm not a victim
to that relationship I'm not a victim to
my finances I'm not a victim to the
relationships in my family I'm an active
part of creating what's occurring and it
can always get better but I'm an active
part that's being the best version of
you and waking up each morning and
saying I like me today I got many things
I can work on but I like me today before
you ever go out on Facebook or any other
social media platform to check to see if
anyone else like you your job is to like
you first and every other like is bonus
that's stepping into the best version of
you setting long-term goals that make
your knees knock a little bit and make
your teeth chatter a little bit those
goals that you don't know exactly how
you're gonna get it done but it's
something that you want to get done it
doesn't it stretches you but it doesn't
stress you your goals are supposed to
stretch you not stress you
those things that combination and when
you live in that capacity and you focus
and you operate in that one that's when
you're living in being the best version
of you if you find that the
relationships around you have toxic
outcomes but I want you to look at
where's the breakdown is the breakdown
in communication is the breakdown in how
you communicate the words you're using
is a breakdown in who you choose to be
around as the breakdown in the
engagement of what you're talking about
what I've learned is that if you're not
talking about things that are high
enough and big enough things that are
inspiring enough you will slip into the
smallness every single time if you don't
choose an intentionally High evolving
encouraging conversation you will slip
into the cracks you will slip into those
crevices of smallness and Petty and
until you get people trained that you're
going to live up here without telling I
need you to know it's not an
announcement it's it's a way of being
and so what do you choose to participate
in it's a stepping over your desire to
hear smallness
gossip
negative feedback it's when someone is
engaging in negative feedback about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook did you stop the
conversation
did you say hold on I don't want to
engage in speaking negative of them at
all why don't you have a conversation
with them it's course correcting
behaviors in your space at the risk at
the risk of losing the relationship but
what you basically do is is you say
here's where I play
here is where I live I'm not visiting
this High Road of Integrity I'm not
visiting this High Road of conscious
thinking and awareness and respect and
humility and and honoring the dignity
and people I don't visit this place I
live here I don't visit this place
I live here and in a loving way anyone
that's engaging with you has two choices
they either engage with you here or they
choose to engage with someone else
now if you find that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger are
you in a moment of resentment are you in
a moment of hurt then you're not living
in your highest Integrity you just visit
every now and again when you come to
this channel
uh oh I see my my Shantae coming out
right now Shantae is my middle name it's
what I do when I start getting real edgy
because I really want you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside and then you don't
leave your conscious neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as yours
people will rise to the occasion or
they'll choose not to rise and they'll
pick other people to be with and hang
with and I know that sounds easier said
than done because some of the people who
are playing at a lower level might be in
family it might be and that's fine too
you can love people it doesn't mean you
have to spend tons and tons and tons of
time if that time cost you something
spend as much time as you can spend as
much time as serves you spend as much
time as they will allow you to spend but
never leave this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are you
don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line and supporting you to either
recognize are you the toxic element are
you surrounding yourself in toxic
element it's to make a commitment where
you live
where am I living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what I do
slip into that small place okay own it
that's conscious awareness that's
powerful own it and then go where do I
want to be and then what's the distance
between here and there what do I have to
do to get there I'd have to say no to
you'll have to participate in we'll have
to ask forgiveness for what I have to
clean up what relationships require
cleaning up and then what declarations
must I make and what decisions must I
live in don't make a decision living
your decision my nephew
was sitting on my great uncle Leonard's
lap and my great uncle Leonard he smoked
cigars for like every year of my life
and I at the time was like 19 and I
never saw him without a cigar so Uncle
Leonard smelled like a what
a really old cigar
and everyone knew Uncle Leonard smell
like a cigar but no one had the courage
to tell Uncle Leonard that he smelled
like a cigar you guys everybody has had
Uncle Leonard somewhere in your life
right because Uncle Leonard was my
grandmother's brother so he had clout
well Jamil was three so he didn't know
he he hasn't been introduced to being
politically correct yet
thank God right so
uh Jameel is sitting on my uncle
Leonard's lap and we're all talking
Jamil stops in the middle of a sentence
and he goes
and the first time he sniffed we no big
deal but the second and the third time
then in this little three-year-old voice
Uncle Leonard
you Tink
and you can hear a pin drop in the room
and everyone in that moment was grateful
that they were not jameel's mother
and we all gazed at her bad mom bad mom
the next thing that fell out of Uncle
Leonard's mouth shocked us all
he looked at Jamil with a long gaze
kind of not knowing what's about to
happen gays
and he said
Jamil
I think you're right
I think I think
for the first time in my entire life
Uncle Leonard put out his cigar and the
next time we saw Uncle Leonard it
smelled like he had just been washed for
days
he was always clean but his clothes just
smell like old cigars and it was very
clear that he got new clothes
see the freedom that a child has
the truth that they stand with think
like a child don't act like a child but
think like a child
be as free as a child see children have
a sense of curiosity children forgive
sooner quicker faster and if you want
something new to come out of your voice
you have to put something new in you in
terms of a commitment my son like I I
would watch the way he would forgive me
he did something wrong one day and I had
to reprimand him and I immediately felt
guilty and I'm in my office he's like
four years old and I'm on my on my
computer and I'm crying because I'm
single mother guilt entrepreneur
and I'm like and he comes around the
corner he goes mommy and I just
reprimanded him he's on a timeout and
all this stuff and I'm upset I'm crying
he's okay
[Laughter]
and he comes around the corner and I'm
and he says Mommy
I was like
yes
do you want to lay down with me
yes
and he goes and he lays out this little
skinny arm and I put my big old head on
that arm
[Applause]
there's something that happens when we
allow ourselves to sit inside Freedom
sit inside
transparency sit inside what I like to
call care frontation
that means I might push up against you a
little bit I might make you mildly to
moderately to significantly
uncomfortable in any form of mediocracy
but it's out of the spirit of love
you want to inspire people with your
voice from your child to your sibling to
your significant other to your community
to the world to this room be willing to
love me enough to tell me your truth
then love me enough to tell me my truth
then love me enough to just tell me the
truth
and and fine
fine
be willing to touch the edge of your own
comfort zone you show me yours and I'll
show you mine
you show me your heart
and I'll show you my love
you let me know that you're willing to
be imperfect and still have a perfectly
giving serving loving life then you give
me permission to let my imperfection out
into the world too
see you want to speak at another level
you got to be willing to love at another
level forgive at another level show up
at another level speak up at another
level pray at another level you have to
be willing on every level to up level
who you be on a daily basis I love to go
back and share some of my favorite
memories with you my fondest and what I
realized they're actually my most moving
memories
one happened over 12 years ago I was in
Toronto Canada with Margaret and this
gentleman walked up to me standing about
six foot two Caucasian man in his
mid-40s and he looked at me and he goes
Lisa
I have a problem with you I said you do
and my heart starts to beat I'm like oh
my God someone doesn't like me what did
I say wrong in their eyes and what how
is this gonna play out
and he goes I have a problem I really
have a problem and I said okay how can I
help you he said I'm an atheist
I don't believe in God
I'm fine not believing in God I'm
comfortable I prefer not to believe in
God I don't believe that there's a God
and I said okay
what's your problem he said my problem
is I love you
I love everything about you
I love the energy you come with I love
the way you speak I love what I feel
when I'm listening to you talk
he said and you keep referring to this
God
as your source
and I don't believe in God
so that's my problem
and I said sir I'm sorry
I'm not sure where your problem lies
I said if if you don't believe in God
you have that right
if you love me
I'm excited because you can feel that I
love you too
and he looked at me and he goes so let
me get this straight
this is not the part where you try to
convert me or try to tell me how wrong I
am or you try to explain to me about
your God so that I can begin to believe
like you believe
this is this is not that part you're not
gonna do that
and I looked about him I said
why would I do that
you're committed to whatever you believe
in my job is to honor your belief system
and it goes see you're doing that thing
again that's making me love you more
that's my problem but I know you believe
in God I said that's not a problem
why don't you keep believing in me and
loving me
I'll keep believing in God and loving
God and we'll keep having this great
experience
after I said that he just grabbed me
and he hugs me
and he held me
and I knew somehow he was holding on to
possibility that's what I choose to tell
myself
he was holding on to the love that he
could feel for me the palatable
non-judgmental
non-persecuting love
and in that moment
I couldn't feel more joy as I held that
man I couldn't feel more joy I I
couldn't feel more happiness that this
is what Ministry is about this is what
touching Souls is about is is to love
the person who thinks that you might not
love them because their belief system it
was just so beautiful at the moment was
so beautiful I mean he held me
and Lenny Drew back and looked at me
he said you're the real deal
and I looked up at him
and I said so are you
and we said our goodbyes I never saw him
again Margaret and I went up to the room
our hotel room that night
and replaying what happened we both just
started to ball just cry
and I said to Margaret Margaret
this is Marketplace Ministry
disguised as a business
[Music]
I'm not in the converting business
I don't need to convert anybody you're
exactly where you choose to be
but I am in the loving business
my job is to love you where you are
and that beautiful gentleman
that day
he reminded me and Margaret I believe
what unconditional love could feel like
to set healthy boundaries you can't just
make an announcement I've been looking
at the Lisa Nichols show and I know you
won't say it like that but things have
got to change no don't announce it like
that don't announce it with that what I
call that stank energy on it don't
announce it with that negative I'm done
you've been using me you no no again
they simply have signed up for the game
that you created the relationship that
you created which was I'm going to give
you can receive you don't ever have to
worry about crossing a boundary with me
so the first thing you need to do is to
set the record straight by apologizing
to the people that you've allowed to
cross your boundaries you have to say I
apologize just say it just like this
just quote me just just like this you
don't have to say you quote me just even
it's your own words you can modify it as
needy but you know what I owe you an
apology
I owe you an apology because I've made
you think that I have no boundaries I've
LED you to believe that I don't need
rest
what I've done is I've you I've overused
my yes
and so I'm not used to saying no and
you're not used to hearing no from me
I've even said yes to you when I needed
to say no and what I know about you is
that you would want me happy
so I apologize
I accept something in motion that
doesn't even work for me I love you I
know you love me and I love the
relationship but I need to make some
tweaks I did this
don't do it in any passive aggressive
way that indirectly blames them know on
your stuff you are a leader own your
mess own your choices own the results I
had to do it hold on I set everyone up
to believe that I can handle everything
I kind of like being the hero of the
story it was my ego or my self-esteem
that needed to be fed for the last 10
years and now I've grown up enough to
realize I don't need that
and so in this new season
I need to set healthier boundaries it's
not about you you never saw my line so
you didn't know that you were crossing
it you never saw the boundaries so you
didn't know where they they existed
that's on me oh now that's Grown Folk
talk that's Grown Folk talk that's adult
that's emotional literacy at its best so
I know it might make your knees knock it
might make your teeth chatter but pull
up your big boy pants pull up your big
girl pants and make it happen
because on the other side of that is the
experience that you deserve and the one
that you're looking for
but it first requires you to do the work
in a previous episode I talked about
your Popeye muscle that's the thing
you've been doing for a long time
already that's the letting everyone
cross your boundaries that's the saying
yes to everyone and then there's that
olive oil muscle you know the muscle
that hangs down here because it's
underdeveloped that's that setting
healthy boundaries muscle
that's not apologizing for how you've
shown up and allowed other people to not
even see your boundary that's owning it
oh
yeah I know it can be intense but it's
so incredibly beneficial so
let's reclaim your boundaries let's
reclaim your joy let's reclaim your life
let's reclaim your future let's reclaim
and design it in a way that serves
everybody because when you do this you
will model for those who are witnessing
you you will model people won't choose
to be out of relationship with you
because you apologize for never setting
boundaries it'll be a little disruptive
it'll be a little uncomfortable it'll be
a little new and then they'll settle in
it and then we know something new and
then you've inspired others to do the
same let me first explain to you what
forgiveness isn't because most people
won't forgive because they have an
incorrect understanding of what
forgiveness is
so forgiveness is not partnering
someone's Behavior it's not excusing
someone's Behavior forgiveness isn't
admitting that you were wrong
forgiveness isn't saying what was done
to me is okay
forgiveness isn't any of those things
forgiveness actually if you really
understand it it has less to do with the
other person and more to do with you and
more to do with your future let's go
back to the oil and water scenario so
forgiveness invites in love invites in
possibility invites in prosperity it
invites in new thinking it invites in
creativity so forgiveness is an
expanding emotion when you forgive
you're opened up for new things
anger is a Contracting emotion it
requires you to shut down to avoid to
shut out to stop talking everything in
Anger is about stopping and shutting
down everything about forgiveness is
about opening up without pardoning
someone's Behavior I want to make sure
I'm clear on that because most people
attach forgiveness to it but you don't
know what he did but you don't know what
she did when you can detach forgiveness
is not about what they did forgiveness
get this forgiveness is about making
yourself available think about you your
body is primary real estate there's only
so much of it it's a finite it's a
finite
space there's only so much space it's
not forever this is your body this so if
this is your primary real estate if this
is your primary real estate your heart
and you're you have anger occupying 20
of it you can never experience a hundred
percent love you can never experience a
hundred percent possibility you haven't
given yourself a chance at a hundred
percent of the things you want most
because your primary real estate your
heart your body your mind is being
occupied with a very intrusive toxic
emotion
less and less about them
nothing to do with them being right or
their behavior being pardoned or the
action it's your your future is paying
for your past
when you hold on to anger
so when you get really connected to the
cost of anger
then it's not about the what
a matter of fact the longer you've been
angry the longer you robbed yourself of
a hundred percent of what you were
worthy of and if someone's betrayed you
if someone's hurt you then you over
everyone deserve a hundred percent love
a hundred percent possibility a hundred
percent but it requires forgiveness and
in many cases it's forgiveness of
yourself in many cases the person you've
been angry at the longest is yourself
and the same rule applies when it comes
to you acknowledge your community see
when you celebrate the people around you
that bring you Joy or that teach you
some of the hardest lessons that you
need to learn the iron that sharpens the
iron the celebrators that celebrate you
those who hold the space for you and
with you pray for you honor you when you
celebrate and lift them up the whole
Tide Rises so I want you to find six
people in your community not out of
obligation but truly out of choice
they can be in your circle in your
family in your business Circle and I
want you to acknowledge them for the
contribution that they bring to your
life what I love about acknowledgment is
that when you acknowledge other people
that it actually makes you happier it's
just this amazing gift of giving and
what I love is that most people would
rather get an acknowledgment from you
than a physical gift that means they
don't necessarily need the perfume they
don't need the sweater they don't need
the new iPhone whatever they want you to
look at them in their eyes and say you
bring value you bring value to my life
I honor you I celebrate you I appreciate
you take time to have a personal moment
with them where you're just seeing them
the number one reason why people feel
sad and disconnected is because they say
they don't feel seen
so in this acknowledgment I want you to
look into their eyes and acknowledge
them for who they are and how they make
your life better when you raise the
community around you the entire Tide
Rises the energy Rises the joy Rises the
expectation Rises and guess what if you
make this a part of your weekly habits
with them I didn't say daily I didn't
say monthly either and I definitely
didn't say annually but if you make this
a part of your weekly find one thing to
acknowledge at least six people in your
community for each week one you'll feel
like you'll feel much more excited but
all of a sudden there's a vibration that
happens because you've created it
there's this energy of let's go do this
because what gets celebrated gets
repeated you want someone to repeatedly
do something wonderful and amazing in
your life you repeatedly acknowledge
them from a genuine place
man it's so powerful when you truly
marry yourself to the acknowledgment
process to the practice of
acknowledgment when you get into the
practice of acknowledgment all of a
sudden people will mirror back to you
you don't acknowledge to get it back you
acknowledge because you want people to
be seen but there's just this this dance
that begins to occur that's absolutely
delicious you know over my career and
I've been in business over 20 years now
uh
people from all around the world
students at every level whether they are
newly into launching their business or
they've been in business themselves for
10 15 years ask the question how do I
overcome fear
I'm about to disrupt you
completely because I am not going to
give you a strategy to overcome fear
because if I even attempt to give you a
strat and I know we're always looking at
stuff reading things out overcome fears
they're probably 10 steps to overcoming
fears somewhere out there they weren't
written by me
and I could never write it because I
don't think
you wait to overcome fear to live the
life of your dreams of the one that you
deserve or to blow your own mind I
personally and I'm teaching you from my
life lessons from what I've studied what
I've applied what I've implemented what
I've fallen from what I've soared from
what I've gotten up from and I don't
think you focus on learning how to
overcome fear though there are things
that helps to mitigate your fear
information mitigates fear training and
developing your skill set mitigates fear
I teach speaking I love teaching people
how to speak powerfully not to speak to
be great but to speak to be
Unforgettable whether you're a speaker
or whether you're a manager whether
you're in retails or network marketing
whatever it is when you open your mouth
you want to be Unforgettable and people
always say Lisa how do I overcome the
fear of speaking I said let's not focus
on the fear of speaking because energy
Grows Where energy goes so let's not
focus on overcoming fear let's focus on
building a muscle that naturally
dissolves fear and that muscle is the
muscle of information the muscle of
education and the muscle of skill set so
if you know more and then you develop
the skill set you won't be as afraid to
do that thing that you're talking about
but the other side to that now I'm going
to disrupt you a bit so the first part
not so disruptive that means go getting
more information give fear What Fear
needs to to to reduce itself meaning
information skill set but this other
part I thought I'm gonna tell you this
might be disruptive
how about
you not try
to mitigate resolve or get past or
overcome whatever you want to call it
how about you not try to do that with
fear
how about you allow the fear to sit with
you you just commit to keep moving
even with the fear
so many times in my life and in my
career I was afraid
the difference between me and most is
that I still move forward with the fear
fear does not have a past to stop you
fear does not have a past to stop you
first of all let me just tell you this
just like compassion just like love just
like respect just like any other feeling
you feel for someone fear is just a
feeling we just give fear more power we
say when compassion comes I hug I love
when understanding comes when Joy comes
when humor comes I laugh but when fear
comes I get to stop what if you change
the meaning to that oh I just just stick
with me right here
what if you change your dance with fear
what if you tell fear you're welcome in
my life because you're gonna come and
keep you away
but when you come I'm not going to stop
every single thing you touch is impacted
by your story as an attorney as a
teacher as an architect there's not one
line of business that you can be in that
a story and a great story won't elevate
your outcome every single line of
business every single line of service
that you're connected to will be
impacted and ideally elevated by the
level in which you're willing to tell
and share your story so let me give you
some guidelines some parameters what I
like to call the bumper rails as if
you're going bowling you know when I go
bowling I ask them to put the little
bumper rails down so I can stay my ball
can get down the lane so let me set up
some bumper rails for you um so that you
understand what makes a great story
so one is the willingness to take risk
most people Vision when they're telling
a story they don't want to take a risk
so the story has it has its limits on
how high it'll go or how deep it'll go
and when you have that then you're
really not at that part that's going to
touch my soul so being willing to take a
risk being clear and concise with your
stories a great story is a show me story
not a Tell me story now this is the
distinction that's the game changer for
most most people are telling a story
they say
um so let me just share with you a
little bit of my story and I'll tell you
and then I'll show you
so as I was building my life there was a
time in my life that was very difficult
it was very challenging true story very
difficult very challenging very
uncomfortable I didn't have a lot of
money I didn't have a lot of Hope and
things just looked dismal at some point
I had to turn my life around at some
point I made the decision that life had
to get better I'm telling you that it's
decent you learn about me then if I were
to show you that story I would say six
days a week
I had to eat beanies and weenies I had
to find money in the crevices in the
corners of my couch so that I can get my
sun milk
there were times when my heart would
beat fast just said what am I going to
have tomorrow
at some point I got sick and tired of my
own story is this going to be my future
no I can't handle it notice a difference
in that second story I completely see
that I just painted a picture same story
now the second one when you show a story
it's gonna require more of you it's
going to require you to find the colors
what were you thinking what were you
experiencing what was going on in your
head instead of telling me you look for
money turn and point now this is
anywhere this is anywhere you are doing
anything I promise you you become a
great Storyteller and you will Captivate
your audience no matter what you're
doing I've captivated investors I've
captivated students I've captivated
Educators because I was willing to show
the story I call it unpacking the story
Vision being willing to tell me what
were you thinking what were you feeling
what were you saying think about a story
as an oral movie and so in an oral movie
think when you're looking at a movie the
first thing they do is they identify
what state of time it is is it
futuristic is it in the now was it back
in the day you notice that based on what
people are wearing how they're talking
so paint that picture for me take me to
that environment set the backdrop up for
me show me what you're going through
instead of saying I was angry you can
tell me you were angry but when you say
the hair on the back of my neck was
standing up I felt the fumes exiting my
nose I thought that my chest was going
to pop and I was going to say something
that I'd regret forever
oh you just showed me you were angry
take that extra time to unpack it why
will most people not do that
because it requires a level of
vulnerability that we're not willing to
share you know when you want to learn
how to trust your intuition more you
know I say and this is me and my walk
and my my belief system that your
intuition is your internal GPS system
your internal God placement system it's
that whisper and sometimes it's that
scream that tells you to LEAP or to be
still your intuition is a combination of
spirit emotion and logic and it's
guiding you and so often we don't hear
our intuition
why don't we hear it because we're
having too much chatter in our head like
the chatter in our head doubt worry
judgment oh my God judgment or fear fear
of other people's perception of you so
your intuition is saying I love to dance
I want to dance I want to sing your
intuition is saying we can have a great
time your intuition is saying I want
love your intuition is saying gosh let's
go take that chance on that writing that
book or let's take that chance on
starting that business then your chatter
comes in no what if I fail so let me
explain this to you your mind your brain
is designed to keep you safe
is designed and it only has the ability
to go back in time in the mental file
cabinet and look at the last time you
tried something like this and it may not
have been
um good or may have ended in some
dangerous situations where people could
judge you and your brain is designed to
protect you that's it your brain desire
to protect you it's logical your
intuition is that spark of passion it's
that spark of Desire it's that spark of
love it's that spark of pull me forward
it's that little bit of radical it's
that a lot of bit of of I want to leave
my fingerprint on this planet your brain
isn't designed to have those same ideas
now now your intuition can kick the
brain in and the Brain can start
thinking of ways too but the intuition
is where it's going to start it's in
your gut it's why when you feel
something you kind of go here you don't
go oh I feel so special you don't say I
feel special here you say I feel it here
I feel it here and so your job
is not to turn down the doubt your job
is to turn up the passion is to turn up
the faith is to turn up the possibility
now still make well-thought-out plans I
always say the best plan is the plan
made I don't care if you have to upgrade
it you have to modify it but if you if
you if you
if you fail to plan then you plan to
fail
so every dream every passion every
desire follow with a plan because that's
where your brain gets excited your brain
goes yeah we got a plan now now you can
believe yourself see you set big goals
and dreams and you have desires and then
you don't achieve it but you don't
achieve it because you didn't set the
plan in place you didn't do the details
and then you stopped believing you could
do it and then you do the biggest
tragedy you stop dreaming
you stop hoping you stop stretching
yourself you stop listening to your GPS
your God placement system that says
you've been put here on a Divine
assignment and your assignment may
change over years guess what your
assignment you had 15 years ago may be
very different from the assignment on
your life today your job
is to turn down the volume in your head
the volume of judgment the volume of
fear the volume of worry the volume of
perfection turn down the volume in your
head and turn up the volume in your
intuition in your solar plex in that God
placement system in that heart space
turn up the volume in that place that
just says what do I want
what ask yourself this tonight today
tomorrow what feels good to my soul and
then be still and be quiet I get asked
the question a lot how do I jump start
again when I've been complacent you know
I I found that I had to ask myself this
question as well for so many years I was
working hard to feed jaylani I was
working hard to give him an equal chance
I have this goal that by the time he was
18 I would have transformed our lives
and I ran hard for it and I worked hard
for it and by the time it was 18 our
lives were completely transformed and
barely recognizable and I found that I
had slowed down a bit still running but
running at about 70 percent and the
challenge that you have to watch out for
is that your 70 could be someone else's
115 because you are such a game changer
so you can impress a lot of people never
playing full out and you can look up in
a Year's past three years has passed
five years have passed and you haven't
played full out for a while because
you've already achieved a lot by some
people's standards but there's still so
much more that you can do I want to
coach you in this way dream a dream or
set a goal that's big enough to make you
get nervous oftentimes if you're not
setting a goal that's beyond three years
out in front of you there's not enough
to run for so I want you to look at your
goals can you achieve them in a year two
years I want you to set a goal for three
years set a goal for five years and set
a goal for ten years yes I said 10 years
when I did this phenomenal program
called Life Book they had me set 10-year
goals and I was so uncomfortable I sat
there silent for a moment I hadn't
thought 10 years out about my life but
if you go out far enough
ten five three then all of a sudden
you're playing for something so much
bigger and then set a goal that makes
your knees knock and your teeth chatter
a bit if you know how to get to your
goal you're not dreaming big enough now
the goal also has to be realistic so has
to be realistic something you can do if
you're currently making eighty thousand
then your goal in three years isn't to
make 500 000 unless you have a path
that's viable to get you there that's
real the thing that's really important
to remember about a goal is that if you
set lofty goals that you will never hit
because they're not realistic in the
first place you have to set realistic
goals not doesn't mean you're not
capable doesn't mean that you don't
believe in yourself but realistic goals
if you set a bunch of unrealistic goals
and you don't hit them every time you
don't hit a goal you you lose just a
little bit of Hope in yourself a little
bit of faith in yourself and then what
happens is you look up five years ten
years from now and you're not dreaming
anymore you're not setting goals anymore
you're afraid to tell anyone so set a
goal that makes your knees knocking your
teeth chatter a bit set a goal that's
three years out in front of you set one
that's five years and set one that's ten
years as a matter of fact set several in
all those timelines and then hook your
kaboos to the train of other people who
are running as fast as you are surround
yourself in a community that inspires
you to want to stand on your tippy toes
they inspire you because they're doing
so much now they believe in values they
believe in faith they believe in family
but they also believe in running hard
playing hard and living big because if
you're the biggest fish in your
community then that's okay you just need
to get a second Community to play inside
of as well and so if you find yourself
going hold on I've become complacent
walk out 15 years and go do I want to
look back in 15 years and this was the
best that I did the answer probably is
no we spend so much time and energy
trying to prevent ourselves from falling
we spend so much energy trying to prove
event of failure we spend so much energy
making sure we're safe
and if we spent
two percent of that energy
exploring how we can soar
exploring how we can play bigger
exploring how we can make memories that
we absolutely will be excited to tell
when we're 85 years old sitting in our
favorite rocking chair if we spent forty
percent fifty percent of that same
energy how would our lives look
differently I'm not saying be Reckless
I'm not saying do it without a plan what
I am saying is so many times I get the
question how do I prevent failure and
I'd love for you to spend that same
energy going how could I ensure that I
soar how can I ensure that I live the
life that I want to tell people about
that I write the story that's going to
be really really good to read so number
one is shift your energy on what you
want to create versus what you want to
prevent because energy Grows Where
energy goes if you've looked at several
episodes you've probably heard me say
that before not because I've run out of
content but because I want to keep
saying it because repetition is not the
mother and father of learning repetition
is the mother father sister brother aunt
and uncle and second cousin of learning
so I'm going to keep telling you this
that energy Grows Where energy goes so
why we want to mitigate and reduce our
risk of falling reduce our risk of
failure we want to spend our dominant
energy on creating possibility and what
we want to run toward now I say that I
say that from Lessons Learned not just
as a teacher but because I for many
years in the early part of my career
unbeknownst to me unconsciously I wasn't
running toward possibility I was trying
to outrun
11.42 cents in the bank like I had in
1994.
so I know that once I was able to get
far enough away from that experience I
started losing motivation I stopped
running as fast I didn't know it I
didn't know why but it's because I knew
I wasn't threatened by ever seeing 11.42
cents again and then I had all my
motivation was gone I was nervous for
about a year I was still in motion still
you know generating a lot of business a
lot of buzz but internally I wasn't
driven the same way until I shifted my
energy and said what am I running toward
the first answer was I don't know
because I've been
trying to outrun something so long that
I wasn't looking forward really looking
for like Horizon for like up for I may
have been looking at the next goal for
the next Target for it but I wasn't
looking at Horizon something so big it
would take me 10 years to get there it
would take me 15 years to get there and
so number one let's create a big
Bodacious like yummy in five years I
want to be here in 10 years I want to
have this let's create something to run
toward that makes your knees knock a bit
and it stretches you it doesn't stress
you it stretches you I love the phrase
willpower but willpower isn't something
you conjure up willpower isn't something
you drink willpower isn't something you
download from Google
what you're talking about is how do I
make the choices that are in alignment
with my highest purpose and my highest
vision for myself that's what you really
want to ask see your life is a physical
manifestation of the choices that you
made up into this moment I'm gonna say
that again because that gets a little
deep and I can go over some people's
head that can hit you sometimes right
between the eyes and you got to hear the
second time so here it goes your life
right now as it exists today your
finances your weight your relationships
your career your self-esteem your
self-image your spiritual awareness all
of that is a result of the choices that
you've made up into this moment big and
small and just so you know your life the
way it appears today is not a result of
a few big choices even though that's the
thing that we look back on we go oh I
shouldn't have moved out of the state I
shouldn't have got into that
relationship I shouldn't have we look at
the big things well I'm here to disrupt
that mindset a bit your life experience
right now is not so much a result of
your big choices why those impact you
it's really a result of a bunch of small
little choices made consistently over a
long period of time
because those are the habits and the
behaviors that you've gotten into so we
can talk about willpower and how do I
build willpower as if it's something
that you can Flex in the gym or
something you can do crunches or ABS or
triceps and build but it's not
the question you should ask
the answer you should be seeking
is what does it take to make my choices
become an alignment with the life that I
say I want to live
now when you say choices it makes it
really sobering because even when you
choose to sit down on yourself it was a
choice so I ask you in this moment what
will it take you to decide to make the
choice today don't even think about
tomorrow don't think about next week but
to make the choice today that's in
alignment with your health goals make a
choice today that's in alignment with
your financial goals it's the small
things it's the extra visit to Starbucks
it's the extra biscuit it's the getting
up early it's 10 more crunches it's
doing squats every time you go to the
bathroom at least that's what I do I do
10. I do ten every time I go to the
restroom I'm already there I'm just
going to keep on going just because I
want to stay in alignment with my goal
and my goal is to have a body that at
least
creates a double take
or or triple date maybe I don't know I
wanted to create a body that is in
alignment with my goal I want to be able
to go paintballing with my nephews and
my son the way I just did recently I
want to be able to go jet skiing so when
I look at my life and my lifestyle that
I want to maintain it requires me to
hike a little longer it requires me to
eat more vegetables and protein it
requires me my my choice of how I want
to live requires my alignment and what I
put in my body or how I stay active in
my body so when I date I don't I don't
do dinner dates I'm not interested in
doing dinner dates you want to date me
let's go on a hike let's go skating ice
skating roller skating let's go on a
walk I want active dates in my dating
experience because that's an alignment
with my life's purpose so
what are you choosing let's not even
look at willpower let's look at choices
because choice is something you can
control in every single moment and the
choice you made yesterday if it wasn't
alignment with your greatest goal and
your highest purpose okay yesterday's
yesterday make a new Choice today you're
not ever condemned or sentenced to
making the same Choice over and over and
over again every day every moment you
have a new opportunity to make a new
choice you know so many people look at
uh fear or even doubt but they look at
fear as if it's the emotional enemy you
know it's the enemy emotion like oh I
can deal with compassion I can deal with
love I can do it understanding but when
fear comes oh my God bad thing no first
of all change your relationship to fear
I've said this before fear is not the
enemy the feeling of fear is just like
any other emotion fear is actually
informing you fear is telling you that
you need to do something either do more
research get some support get some
insight study a little more slow down
fear is actually feeding you so then ask
yourself the question what do I need to
do think or go get to dissipate this
fear because remember fear is fear
becomes present when you've made up
something that could happen in the
future and it makes you afraid right now
like oh my God I'm afraid I can get hurt
in this relationship oh my God I'm
afraid I'm gonna lose my money you're
just projecting a story that you made up
then back into that fear and go okay
wait then what do I need to do to
minimize the fear that I might get hurt
what do I need to do to minimize the
fear that I might lose my money what do
I need to do of course you can't uh 100
eliminate the possibility but you can
greatly reduce the chances by asking
what am I afraid of what am I afraid
that's going to happen
and then secondly recognize that fear
doesn't mean stop
people think oh I'm afraid let me stop
okay that's a choice to stop Fear
doesn't necessarily mean stop Fear might
mean proceed with caution
or proceed with more strategy fear
doesn't whenever I'm feeling fear it
doesn't tell me this I don't even think
now to stop with the fear I do think to
slow down go get some help go get some
inside voice my fear so that it's not
just all in my head
recognize that
fear is going to come in when you're
playing bigger than you've ever played
before I
say if your knees aren't knocking and
your teeth aren't chattering just a
little at least then you're not playing
big enough the bigger you play the more
you're gonna feel your knees knock and
you're gonna hear your teeth chatter and
I'm always playing big I'm always
feeling my knees knock and I'm always
hearing my teeth chatter but I've
created a relationship with that fear to
go hold on
let's say fears right here fear what are
you telling me
because fear really is
it's it's a story it's
it's something you think could happen
and could it happen yeah
but could it not happen
yeah
so
don't try to outrun fear
don't try to outrun doubt and definitely
don't wait until doubt and fear are gone
before you move
find out what doubt and fear needs to
dissipate into the nothingness that it
always was
what does it need
and then understand that action
brings Clarity so the more you move
forward the more action you're in the
more clarity you get because action
breeds clarity
and Clarity comes with action
so many times you're sitting on the
sideline waiting waiting to get
completely clear before you take any
action and Clarity is waiting for you to
get an action to create clarity
so be willing
be willing
to play full out
a little nervous if you want another
amazing Lisa Nichols video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe I'll see you
there